sortez les clairons sorte électro prête
je sais pas c'est l'expression de la
bonne en tout cas ce soir sortir tout ce
que vous voulez et tout ce qui fait du
bruit parce qu'aujourd'hui c'est le jour
du grand renouveau de huawei je sais pas
si on peut dire ça comme ça en tout cas
aujourd'hui c'est le jour du lancement
du p 40 pro de huawei un smartphone que
j'attendais parce que oui vous le savez
vous connaissez l'année 2019 de huawei
je vais pas du tout vouloir faire waouh
et revient en force
j'en ai déjà parlé le jour en vous
présentant le myhtique cesse par
smartphone pliable puis avoue clients
faites comme vous voulez rial ça marche
et à ce moment là j'en ai déjà parlé il
ya un grand changement qui s'opère grâce
à la galerie la galerie on en parlera
dans quelques jours aujourd'hui on va
vraiment concentré sur la partie
hardware la partie matérielle à cette
heure française
avec ce nouveau smartphone ce nouveau
pékin rendront alors je sais pas si vous
vous souvenez on vient en 2019 est
annoncé le p 30 pro un smartphone
camilla peu gif a pas mal de monde et
notamment au niveau de la photo parce
que si on re situe comme en font foi
nous a joué avec ces modèles vous avez
le modèle pay qui est présenté en début
d'année p 30 et 40 qui est un modèle axé
sur la photo au partenariat une fois de
plus avec anelka
le p 30 pot était très bon le paie 40
projets intéressants et je vous le
présente tout à l'heure vous allez voir
ça et en fin d'année vous avez la série
might la série mec est plus axé sur la
performance avec notamment le mettre en
pot que je vous ai présenté un arrière
qui était aussi un super produit point
de vue hardware on va donc aujourd'hui
se parler deux produits lactés dans
cette petite voix temporalité il pas
dans la boîte
je les planqués là bas il est sur le
côté parce qu'effectivement ça fait déjà
un petit moment que j'ai dans les mains
que je le teste
oui je sais sous embargo je ne vous ai
rien dit je n'ai pas droit
il est là il est beau il est prêt et
vous allez voir il ya pas mal de belles
surprises voilà donc la boîte du p 40
pro ya rien de bien exceptionnel quand
vous la regardez comme ça ils ont
surtout il ya une chose qu'ils aient
vraiment tirer votre gars logo wl p40
pro qui a été fait en partenariat avec
les cas mais plus important se situe ici
c'est clairement posée c'est affirmer
les choses sont très claires ça
fonctionne ici avec la galerie de huawei
et aucun autre catalogue d'applications
et justement cette galerie abonnez-vous
puisqu'on en parle dans quelques jours
j'ai vraiment m'expliquer comment ça
marche y'a rien
hier dingue d'un point de vue packaging
extérieur c'est simple efficace le
smartphone se trouve ici à l'intérieur
vous avez un petit logo ben ouais avec
le contour du smartphone qu'on commence
à deviner si je les ai enlevés bien
évidemment donc vous ne verrez pas je
voulais montrer dans quelques instants
ici de courir votre tiroir de cartes sim
vous arriver qu'un gros blocs de charge
qui massive
je vous le monde dans quelques instants
vous pouvez déjà voir que ça ça me sera
chargé très très très très rapidement
vous avez un câble usb usb c'est vous
avez des petits écouteurs qui vont en
revanche et en usb c'est ya rien de
banal mais ça fait le boulot sympa un
tympan
voilà le paie 40 procès lui
regardez moi ce truc très cool très
jolis modèles qui réalisé par mois ou
alors si on regarde tout de suite ce qui
frappe ce qu'on voit ici c'est qu'on a
cette espèce de suppression que les
puces à une bloom gros son coach sur le
côté qui vient vous intégrez un double
module photo double caméra on va se le
détail et dans quelques instants
mais surtout ce qui est très jolie vous
avez un écran qui appelle complètement à
l'immersion avec des bords qui sont très
très très fin et très fin sur le côté
qui viennent à peine dessiner le
smartphone et c'est très léger bord qui
est extrêmement fin en bas place belle
fête à l'écran vous avez un smartphone
qui est vraiment très jolie très bien
profilée et je préfère on paie 30 proxy
quand même pas mal utilisé dernière qui
avait ses petites encoches sur le haut
le côté bull pour l'instant je trouve ça
toujours pas parfait je préférais
d'avoir des caméras intégrées sous
l'écran qui deviennent invisibles
on verra ça en 2021 je suppose c'est pas
cela complètement idéal c'est pas la
partie que j'ai préféré mais la partie
que je préfère c'est vraiment ce côté
légèrement galbées soit côté vous avez
le bouton pour le monter le volume mais
pour le bc qui est juste là le bouton
pour venir l'allumer et l'éteindre avec
un petit liseré rouge qui est très sympa
pour trouver sur dessous un petit haut
parleur pour trouver de la prise en usb
c'est vos tiroirs de cartes sim qui est
juste là le petit micro qui est là de ce
côté là vous n'avez absolument rien le
micro pour la réduction de bruit de
l'infrarouge
vous avez un module photo qui et mastoc
quadruple module photo 1 2 3 4
flash led ici en dessous il n'y a
absolument rien et 120 du smartphone et
a trouvé le branding huawei alors ici
écrit not for sale parce que c'est un
modèle qui est destiné à la presse
si vous le voyez bien qu'écrit juste ici
un modèle que je trouve vraiment très
sympa très jolie qui tient bien en main
un smartphone avec un capteur
d'empreinte digitale intégrée sous
l'écran qui est positionné assez haut
mais au final ça se tient très bien
parce que voyez on pose le doigt et
déverrouille extrêmement rapidement
sinon je mets en face ils me reconnaît
je devais rentrer rapidement dans tous
les cas ces liens à noter que vous avez
un déverrouillage intelligent vous
pouvez venir approcher un objet
bluetooth convenable déverrouiller très
rapidement par exemple votre monde
connecté de voir où il sera parfaitement
bien à faire lorsque vous avez
enregistré votre visage pour la
reconnaissance faciale et bien vous
pouvez venir enregistrer un look
alternative qui vous permettra de
déverrouiller rapidement si par exemple
vous avez des lunettes de soleil que
vous avez une casquette un smartphone
que je trouve très bien réussi en termes
de prise en main format compact on
accède très facilement aux boutons sur
le côté et a juste un truc à voir c'est
qu'ici voyez à cause du module photo eh
bien ça bouge un petit peu bon il va
falloir mettre une coque de protection
ça va tour équilibré donc c'est pas
problématique qui est très intéressant
c'est l'écran vous avez un écran ici
oled de 6,58 pouces 2640 par 1200 pixels
à 441 pixels par pouce
le ratio des créances et de 19,8 9e un
écran que je trouve bien calibrée il ya
deux trois petits détails à venir voir
le fus personnellement au niveau des
monnaies température couleurs moi je
préfère être calibrée en normal et en
couleurs chaudes par défaut vous allez
retrouver en vivent
et comme ça par défaut je trouve un peu
plus bleue trouve que les coloris sont
très triade normal se consacre à mettre
plutôt bien chaude c'est à dire vous le
réchauffé c'est un peu plus confortable
il pour mondain et meilleur compromis
là-dessus il ya un autre point à voir
également c'est la fréquence de
rafraîchissement de l'écran ces taux de
rafraîchissement ici vous avez deux
possibilités soit du 90 hertz soit du 60
hertz 60 hertz ses classiques 90 hertz
ça marche c'est à consommer un peu plus
de batterie il vous aurait un peu plus
de fluidité
ici vous avez alors la mono qui s'est
tue son côté sur la tranche panneaux par
leur saison vous a donc pas d'expérience
pedro par contre vous avez beaucoup de
choses c'est très très très très fort
dans sa gamelle de baisser d'une pompe à
rebours en dessous reid pour pas faire
peur à vos voisins
l'expérience ce document la main est
plutôt bien pas extrêmement immersive à
cause de la source que vous avez
uniquement de ce côté là mais ça fait le
boulot
si vous regardez ici vous n'avez
absolument aucun haut parleurs pour
pouvoir passer beaucoup de fils le haut
parleur qui va se situer ici dans la
zone du milieu directement sous l'écran
néanmoins rassurez vous vous posez votre
quête ici vous entendez le son est bon
la qualité est bonne et personnes autour
de vous ne pourra l'entendre si vous
voulez améliorer significativement la
qualité ce que je vous conseille
d'utiliser un casque sans fil pourquoi
pas des freebox 3 que vous allez pouvoir
connecter grâce au bluetooth 5 points
côté performances à un smartphone qui
fait vraiment le taf qui les verrouille
rapidement qui extrêmement réactif
quelles que soient les usages que vous
allez on
il faut savoir que là dessus vous
tourner quand même sur ce qui se fait de
mieux aujourd'hui chez huawei vous avez
un kirin 990 un smartphone 5 g oui vous
avez un modèle 5g à l'intérieur vous
avez 8 gigas de ram 256 go de stockage
extensible grâce à une carte micro sd
j'ai fait un test souvent tout où vous
arrivez à 466 1765
autant dire qu'on est un smartphone qui
est vraiment très puissante a dit à
partie de l'autonomie ça va être
compliqué de vous donner les résultats
tout de suite parce que ce n'était pas
assez longtemps que j'utilise laissez
moi un peu plus de temps aujourd'hui on
est vraiment dans une découverte plutôt
du hardware je vous sortirez mon test
dans quelques temps vous invite donc dès
maintenant vous abonner comme ça vous
saurez tout il faut savoir vous avez si
une batterie de 4200 milliampères heures
que les 100 l'optimisation logicielle de
huawei je pense que ce smartphone vais
pouvoir garder une journée et demie à
deux jours je veux pas trop m'avancer là
dessus mais j'imagine que c'est à peu
près là dessus qu'il faut tabler ça
dépend bien évidemment une fois de plus
des usages de ce que vous vous allez en
faire ça dépend du taux de
rafraîchissement de votre écran ça
dépend si vous passez sur un dark mode
ou pas afin ya pas mal de petites
modifications des petites optimisations
qui vont vous faire soit économiser la
batterie soit consommé davantage et owen
sorti une fois de plus l'artillerie
lourde avec un très gros blocs de cham
c'est la superstar de 40 watts et vous
avez également de la recharge rapide en
adduction puisque vous pouvez monter
jusqu'en 22,5 soit autant vous dire que
si vous n'avez pas pensé à charger votre
smartphone vous vous levez le matin la
tête un port paris des masses il n'est
pas chargé
vous le prenez vous le branchez vous
allez vous doucher parce que vous vous
êtes quelqu'un de propre et vous allez
voir qu'il est rechargée extrêmement
rapidement donc ça s'est vraiment bien
là dessus vous avez également de la
charge inversée owen où il avait déjà
sorti il ya un petit moment
ça vous permet de recharger vos petits
écouteurs de recharger un autre
smartphone très facilement vous
l'activez dans vos paramètres vous posez
l'autre smartphone dessus ou ce que vous
voulez et ça va vous rechargez ses
bières c'est pratique et si c'est la
version 10.1 de est muée en une
interface qui a amélioré des options de
déverrouillage et d'accès biométrique
qui ont été optimisés c'est pas une
révolution mais apple petites
modifications qui sont plutôt bien vous
pouvez voir wayne cher vous avez une
navigation par jet ski extrêmement
intuitif qui marche bien car api que je
trouve vraiment cool et bien évidemment
vous avez catalogue d'applications de
huawei qui situent juste ici c'est la
galerie alors la galerie je vous en
parle dans quelques jours sur une vidéo
dédiée vous expliquerez tout savoir
comment il marche donc abonnez-vous
comme ça vous aurez tous les détails et
toutes les informations ballon
maintenant il ya un autre pote
extrêmement intéressant qui est
probablement peut-être même le point le
plus attendu c'est la partie photo
vidéo puisque wii l'année dernière où
ils avaient frappé à très très très très
fort avec son pétrole pro il ya vu un
gars qui était énorme
on va regarder ce que nous propose cette
année une fois de plus avec cette année
le paie 40 pro et bien voyez vous avez
quatre capteurs photo le premier héros
ici c'est un ultra grand-angle 20 40
mégapixels ouverture de f 1.8
vous allez retrouver en dessous un grand
angle de 50 méga pixels avec une
ouverture de f
1.9 avec leurs phares du capteur air y/y
b red yellow blue blue qui vous
permettra de capter plus de luminosité
néanmoins toutes vos photos vont sortir
non pas en 50 méga pixels mais en 12
mégapixels
si vous voulez des photos 50 méga pixels
il faut venir voir le mode pro et là
vous avez 50 méga pixels regarder je
vous le mets l'assureur-santé plus
facile 50 méga pixels qui est barrée
vous appuyez dessus et là vous pouvez
venir ajouté des photos en 50 méga
pixels et si vous avez un zoom
périscopique il vous faudra sortir des
photos x 5 en optique x 10 en hybride et
x 50 ans numérique de 12 mégapixels qui
ouvre à f 3.4 autres améliorations ont
été faites par rapport à l'année
dernière c'est que l'année dernière ce
pas si vous souvenez mais son capteur
principal
il avait mis le capteur air y/y b comme
je vous l'expliquais red yellow yellow
blue avec tout du jeu n'est pas du verre
qui laisse passer plus de lumière et
ensuite le verre ils viennent de travail
est artificiellement et ils ont fait
exactement la même chose sans leurs
capteurs périscope et vous avez donc le
capteur est y/y b qui vient
significativement amélioré les photos en
basse luminosité
autre point qui est intéressant vous
avez une stabilisation optique sur
l'ensemble du bloc et notamment sur la
partie grand angle et périscopique vous
avez donc une stabilisation optique mais
également une stabilisation électronique
tandis qu'ici vous y retrouver une
petite caméra c'est la caméra tough time
of light qui vous servira pour la
profondeur de champ et pour toutes les
utilisations en trois dimensions tandis
qu'à l'avant il vous le voyez ici vous
avez un double capteur photo vous avez
une 32e mégapixels ouvre à f 2.2 et vous
avez également une caméra tough qui va
venir agir pour de la commande gestuelle
mais également pour le mode portrait
parce que oui là dessus vous avez un
mode portrait au niveau de la caméra de
celle ci la caméra tough vous allez
retrouver à l'avant mais également à
l'arrière
elle va venir vous savez pour avoir une
meilleure compréhension de la scène et
je vous prends un exemple c'est pas tant
que vous prenez en photo que vous êtes à
contre-jour elle va pouvoir savoir où
vous êtes dans la photo si vous êtes un
contre-jour elle va lancer le hdr va
changer l'exposition on y re
complètement optimiser vos photos et ça
de manière parfaitement invisible c'est
la même chose en tête que vous avez à
l'avant mais celle là en plus à leurs
dires de participer au déverrouillage en
trois dimensions point de vue logiciel
n'ya pas gros
innovation là dessus pour trouver les
photos portraits clichés nocturne
ouverture vidéo pro et le plus plus avec
du ralenti panoramique monochrome
objectif faire ça faisait pas mal de
petites choses en fonction de ce que
vous souhaitez faire vous savez c'est
assez rigolote bon après voilà tout ça
c'est des trucs un peu marrant mais bon
[Musique]
en photo pendant passé sur un ultra
grand angle mais vous monte également
avec vous une périscopique puisqu'à x 50
au niveau de la vidéo bourrée filmer
jusqu'à quatre cas à 60 images par
seconde et pour vos services vous pouvez
venir filmer en 4k à 60 images par
seconde
il ya un truc que j'ai pu tester que je
trouve vraiment bien au niveau de la
vidéo si vous avez vraiment une super
stabilisation quel que soit votre caméra
que vous soyez sur le capteur principal
que vous veniez zoom est monté très haut
vous pouvez venir monter six voiliers
jusqu'en x 10 un des gros points forts
c'est travail qui est fait au niveau de
l'intelligence artificielle et notamment
une amélioration de la reconnaissance de
scène des couleurs et du mode portrait
donc de façon plus globale
on a une amélioration de l'image vous
voilà quelques photos que j'ai pu faire
avec le p 40 pro bien évidemment à cause
du confinement on va pas eu à
l'extérieur on va rester dans le jardin
alors là nous avons un beau crocodile de
mon fils c'est un jeu rassurez-vous
capteur principal on passe sur un ultra
grand angle au stand et se rapprocher on
vient vous me voyez quand même là une
précision alors on voit que le jeu est
un peu dégueulasse mais on peut venir se
rapprocher et ça fonctionne ultra
grand-angle capteur principal et ensuite
on bien zoomer capteur principal ultra
grand-angle et on s rapprocher tout
doucement et ont récupéré pas mal de
détails
mais si on veut aller plus loin utiliser
le zoom périscopique c'est faux si ce
qu'il vous faut c'est ça on vient où met
on vient se rapprocher se rapprocher se
rapprocher et là on est sur la zone
périscopique x 50 alors la qualité est
pas complètement folle
on garde cet effet waouh ça fait le
boulot capteur principal
ultra-grand-angle une différence de
couleur entre capa principe à une trêve
en tant que vous le voyez si au niveau
de l'herbe la voyez elle est un peu
moins verte un peu moins saturé et
l'aclu très grand-angle et les quatre
plus vers beaucoup plus saturés et
ensuite on vient se rapprocher on se
rapproche on se rapproche et on se
rapproche sur les fleurs c'est pareil ça
marche très très très bien capteur
principal ultra grand-angle et lanvin se
rapprocher au plus près de la fleur une
fois de plus le mode portrait orne les
détails ici autour des doigts ça va ça
fonctionne au niveau de la tête c'est
bien des tours et et ça c'est grâce aux
capteurs tough qu'il ya vraiment vous
reconnaitre et vous détacher du reste et
ça voyez ça marche très très très bien
et on peut même devenir complètement
vous détacher mettre à fond noir
derrière la caméra de celle fille aussi
fait
job ça c'est des photos que j'ai fait en
conditions de faible luminosité il fait
quasiment nuit d'ailleurs vous le voyez
ce que vous avez la lumière qui vient de
la porte qui est là et ça fait le boulot
bien évidemment je sortirai mon test
ultérieurement avec beaucoup plus de
photos là c'est pareil il ya très très
peu de lumière on va pas
particulièrement il rendu quand même
qualitatif au niveau de votre sim pour
émettre soit une double sim soit une
carte sim ncaa pour bien voter veulent
stockage jusqu'à 256 giga faut savoir
également qu'il est compatible estime un
smartphone qui est du wifi 6 vous avez
du nlc pour le paiement dématérialisé il
est certifié ip 68 résistants à l'eau et
à la poussière et bien évidemment c'est
un smartphone 5g et ça c'est bien alors
qui dit smartphone 5g dit également
smartphone compatible 4g et 3g il est
disponible en noir et en gris
le cac40 pro disponible dès maintenant
dans la configuration 8 + 256 gigaoctets
riffs de 1099 euros
pour l'instant on n'a pas de date de
sortie mais une période de pré commandes
qui est allongé d'ailleurs si vous
intéresse j'ai mis un lien en bas dans
la description personnellement je trouve
plutôt bien
j'aime bien l'écran jeunes via le
formage et de la sauce soja trouve assez
rapide et convaincante
il ya peut-être deux petits paiements le
premier petit bémol c'est l'écran ici on
a un écran 80 des actes et non pas
d'écran 120 hertz comme on commence à
retrouver aujourd'hui dans les
smartphones et plus haut de gamme de
2020 à côté de ça la différence je suis
pas sûr que pour le commun des mortels
sur les usages qu'on en a ce soit ce cas
le plus flagrant
le deuxième point c'est son l'appareil
photo et notamment au niveau du zoom
périscopique que vous aimez à l'arrière
parce que oui effectivement l'année
dernière vous au moins vous avez surpris
avec son thé 30 pro avec un zoom
périscopique x 50
et c'est vrai qu'ici on retrouve
également un zoom périscopique soit 50
on aurait pu s'attendre à voir une plus
grosse évolution à aller un peu plus
loin mais ce n'est pas le cas mais
attention il ya un truc est très
intéressant et qui arrive justement je
vous dis ça je vous dit rien sa cp 40
promet on va pas aller dans les temps à
venir d'un p40 pro + qui lui par contre
en zoom périscopique fois sans un
cinquième capteurs qui se résout map tic
x 3 et zoom périscopique ta vie ne
commencera pas à x 5 mai à x 10 mais ça
m'apparaît plus tard une pour l'instant
je ne dis absolument rien à vous dire
comment vous trouvez ce smartphone est
ce que vous trouvez intéressant est ce
que vous êtes convaincus par ce p 40 pro
est ce qu'il pourrait vous séduire
vous trouvé intéressant est ce que vous
pourriez vous laisser tenter marc qui
m'a tout ça bien évidemment en bas en
commentaire et s'il vous intéresse je
vous ai mis un lien en bas dans la
description sur ce je vous embrasse
je leur dis vous dès demain pour
continuer à parler de textes vous allez
voir il ya plein de sujets extrêmement
intéressant à venir à demain nous
élisons
[Musique]